[Music]
please be advised please be advised
spoiler alert spoiler alert well guess
what everybody this is exciting
this is exciting the war for the Planet
of the Apes spoiler up with a Planet of
the Apes expert I don't you say with a
guy from the Planet of the Apes as the
guy who's been from the future I am from
the planet Venus
one of the few humans that can talk
beyond oh yeah I got over it got over
the virus yeah little echinacea what
yeah right I'm keeping sure hmm alright
I was just all that clean living out the
Forbidden Zone I thought oh there's a
reason why the color forbidden my red
mm-hmm what I'm talking about that kind
of weekend it's a front it's a friend
ladies and gentlemen this is our good
friend Matt Weinhold
hi written for the site yes yes part of
comedy film era - I love you guys
and there's that's the main thing one of
the writer Larry very fond of both of
you I'm not even being smarmy Hollywood
you're making it uncomfortable yes I
like to look get it out of the way get
it out of the way i'm all hands the
first 15 minutes and then we can relax
and go down yeah once I get my little
program at Ohio one of the writers on
the comedy film nerds book with a hard
chapter and all yeah because he's all
hands that's because our hands are all
over everything the octopus season right
online handle yeah squiddly diddly
Maddie the activist white hole in studio
any of Zona podcast monster part monster
party which I've been on you've been on
Evan now what I love that well my
favorite episode seriously
what you
like that was both of these were so much
fun Chris yours telling the whole story
of your movie or was like them yeah it
was just like pure joy and then you when
we did the crossovers with the Jack Lord
thing and Captain Kirk blew my mind
loved it it was so it was so your show
is so fun what I love about it is it's a
commitment it's like we don't just go do
the podcast you you pencil in the
evening yeah you're going to a party
yeah you I tell you we have dinner we
have drinks sure you can do an hour but
no whatever now you come in there's food
we start drinking then we socialize for
a little bit yeah then we record it
really is it's an evening party anywhere
that has free food yeah we've learned we
will learn that across the board Denise
Crosby when we had her on she was like
all you had to do is say free meal
where's my grant what do you want for
dinner I'm like I'm in whatever you guys
need me to do we do in body painting
what do we do whatever you guys are into
fariñas whatever I don't care we got to
do a furry we refer you got to do a
furry and that's that's on camera
hey man if there's tofu Pad Thai Domino
well you know we we you know peanuts
comic or anything I just want to say
that the water that you provided me here
very cold very very pure thank the good
people at all things comedy yeah I do
thank you people at all things comedy so
let's get into it let's talk about war
for the planet real quickly
Oh real quick now all right anyone's new
and we always gotta do this every
episode okay so every ever ever spoiler
up we always get new listeners so we
need people to know we're going to
discuss every single aspect of war for
the planet of the apes including the
ending if you've not seen this movie and
want to and don't want it spoiled you
need to hit the pause button and get
yourself into a motion picture cinema
and watch this that's all right yes
sweet too sweet that game said um let's
get into it yes no Chris and I have
talked about it on the regular episode
we go we both liked it I
like I felt dawn was a little stronger
out of the three or little stronger yes
so now Matthew I found my bloated look
you can alright as much as I like this
movie I did I agree with you though I
think the second one was definitely the
better film here was the thing about
this film okay it really was like we
were talking about this really felt like
Apocalypse Now with apes and then I was
saying like well that was you know how
many of these are we going to have we
just said you know Skull Island was like
all these shots from Apocalypse Now that
with with a giant ape like a whole
generation just discovered that film
right exactly all right we're going to
put your head every good yes so but you
know we have new Chris what not a whaler
alert yeah yeah Chris goes nuts yeah go
ever loses a ship so we literally have
Woody Harrelson as as Chris and they're
they're coming after him now in the
trailer there was a shot that never made
sense to me
okay that was only in the trailer all
right I'm sensing that loved again
that's my buggy I can't wait to let him
go off by that just the first one it can
I just throw in right now no matter what
happens when no matter what I say I
would just want to say I recommend going
to see this film yeah okay okay so there
were these they're they're helicopters
in this in the trailer my for
helicopters but they're fighting the
other soldiers I know the Apes aren't
manning the helicopters so I know
clearly there's some other conflict
going on so I thought that was on the
one hand interesting where basically you
have this rogue military operation with
basically Colonel Kurtz who went up you
know out of his mind love that idea and
then and then you know all the other
soldiers coming down and basically
taking away his command and then you
have the Apes in the middle of it
right um so I did not see coming no I
didn't see that I didn't think that that
Woody Harrelson was the guy that went
nuts and did it out of and that scene
where he is talking to Caesar and he's
explaining and you realize God his he's
crazy logic for doing this like I get it
I get where he's coming from it's it's
again I wanna find out he was chewing up
the scenery yet but again it's it's um
to to the Colonel Kurtz of Apocalypse
Now who makes those points of you know
we [ __ ] napalm children but a guy
can't write [ __ ] on his on his helmet
like that's detestable which is the
whole point of Apocalypse Now was to
show like we do not have the moral high
ground here as we think that we do as
Americans but we war is awful so he's
like look if we're going to go into war
Colonel Kurtz I'm obviously saying this
if we're going to go into war let's cut
the [ __ ] let's cut these [ __ ]
namby-pamby rules like let's just far
second cut cutting people's heads off
and stringing them the [ __ ] up and we're
gonna you know and that all that it's
like they put of a crucifix yes right so
that to me was interesting to then say
well this is a guy that's seeing the
potential end of the human race at the
hands of these vile genetically
engineered apes right I think what am i
entirely wrong no I think one of my
favorite lines was when he realized that
these soldiers were not coming to join
Woody Harrelson they were coming to
fight him and he goes to Caesar well
don't get too excited the only thing
they're more scared of than me is you
yeah that's not like they were going to
come and liberate the apes all right so
I'm at so man very patient very cry yes
but I feel now I think it's time to
embellish I like if you were just
sitting a certain part I didn't know
you'll be like this guy's ready to go
you know I love the last one and all of
them have things in them that make you
go little squirrel that's a little
sloppy screenwriting but they've got
better
like I thought Don was better than Rhys
and so I'm ready to like this and
especially when you sit down in that
theater and you watch what they have
done with these Apes the technical
achievement of what they have done
it's mesmerizing oh and II said we're
talking about this anti service needs an
Oscar nominee
I mean you forget you're watching like
every single shot is computer-generated
caPSURE like you know they the Apes
didn't really ride the horses right yes
so here's the thing like I mean on you
know movie actors usually get their
nominations and show how good of an
actor they are in the close-up because
it's the little on a 40-foot screen
the little emotional micro expressions
are magnified and you go wow that's so
powerful Andy Serkis is doing this he's
not okay in the mocap suit yes and it
shows you also two things then it shows
you how advanced the technology is that
they can take his actual human reactions
and make them look like he and Mary it
an area can an ape so that's fantastic
and there's some there's some act some
scenes I'm like well that's it that's an
acting that just [ __ ] clip for the
Oscar nomination yeah oh yeah there are
so there are so many moments in there
where I am genuinely moved watching
computer-generated imagery mixed with
motion capture right and astounded that
I'm feeling this yeah because there's an
actor underneath yes and it's and I mean
I really was mesmerized by that now in
any movie like that that where you're
kind of wowed by the effects then it
gets to a point where that kind of
starts to wear off and now you're in the
movie you need the story yeah and and
there's just so much of it that I just
don't understand like even the heavy
hitting political stuff okay that's fine
whatever as long as you're telling me a
good story like what specifically well
you know build the wall okay you know
and also I never understood the idea of
so in the movie you know they're
building this they're making the Apes
build this they've captured all the Apes
by the way got him in a prison camp it
wasn't a very good wall well that's the
receipt are you go
there's no taught them to build a good
wall yeah where's the Army Corps of
Engineers then you'll have any of those
left how about Bob Vila they were
literally just throwing debris into a
pile that was the wall yeah and and did
anyone they must have been some sort of
intelligence that let them know
helicopters are coming right so unless
it's a dome yeah right I mean so should
we build more sphere ground too
rockets or supports um or or ditches
like traps things like art bestie and
that's the other thing that's the other
big problem I had with both sides of
this war which Willie there wasn't award
the war was between the humans right but
and I was hoping there would it be in a
poor but that's fine I'm going in with
my own expectations that movie doesn't
have to fulfill those it has to tell a
good story and this in this movie the
humans and the Apes first of all have no
concept of the idea of stealth like the
idea of maybe we shouldn't be hiding
behind the rock so close to the front
gate of the prison when we're doing our
reconnaissance maybe as we're coming
into this human settlement we shouldn't
be riding our horses right down the
middle of the street I mean all over the
place I'm thinking myself Caesar you're
a terrible leader you and Rick from The
Walking Dead should hang out because
you're both awful well there's no ninja
eggs you know there's no there's no step
it's hard to be effective and also
wouldn't you think that after all the
[ __ ] that's gone down before that
someone should suggest a Caesar Caesar
might want to come up with this idea by
himself like hey maybe we need some cars
maybe we need some bigger guns like
instead of like we have to phase out the
whole spear thing like come on you are
in danger and you know that they're
coming for you know even if you're like
oh my god they caught us off guard
because there was the the white ape that
you know turned on us and gave our
location alright well then we're going
to find you at some point because they
have technology and you don't and so
like that was the other thing too is I
was expecting they would be a little
more fortified by this point in the
trilogy that and and more proactively
like going out stealing weapons killing
soldiers getting their guns and ammo and
and fortifying our selves it because
they did have that they would they would
take any of the weapons that they would
get off the soldiers they would actually
use the guns but did it seem like they
didn't have too many they didn't have
too many it almost felt like Matt Reeves
was directed it and one of the writers
should have watched the original
Red Dawn more because right isn't like
what green all you know I like both
versions of that movie I even like the
remake of that movie that's a bold
statement ha ha ha if you're going to be
critical of this one and then you're
going to say you're going to critical
for for my lives but you like this but
what but see one is one in my mind is a
b-movie and the other one is like this
is we're taking this to another level
one is more cartoon especially the
remake yeah there we make this cartoon
yeah okay alright this isn't a this
isn't a red ton no I think we should now
change that dog ape Don so now I want to
talk about this virus this okay that
because my recycled in the movie oh yeah
weird time to bring it up Chris the
quote via the quote the simian flu you
know we're all infected let's face it
okay I'm went on this show oh can I ask
you a question about that right off the
bat
mm-hm I and this could be just because
I'm dense but I I didn't like when they
find the little girl yes I had no idea
what was going like the idea that she
had blood coming out of her nose I
didn't know who she was I didn't know
what her relationship was to the guy I
didn't realize that the it took me
almost the the entire movie to figure
out that the blood from her nose oh she
because she has the virus and anyway go
go on with what you were saying what I
was going to say that girl is actually
Nova that becomes yeah Jo in the in the
original Planet smooze what I was going
to say is the virus like I would have
liked to have seen a little bit more of
specific rules the way these were kind
of buttoned up a little bit because the
virus the way it was presented is that
okay this is a virus that's affecting
the Apes making them smarter and is also
making the humans mute and dumber
so if that's the case then when they
found the little girl why didn't it
affect the father because obviously the
doll was infected because that's how
woody harrelson got infected yes it's
almost immediately almost immediately
but the father wasn't affected so is
this I'm kind of resistant something
that's my excuse me yeah I didn't know
what was going on like right if he was
also mute then you go oh okay right
here's what confused me I had a lot of
time
issues with regards to this is a lead
this is a prequel this is a lead up to
the original plan of the Apes right so
and maybe this has been explained
elsewhere and I've missed it by fan
fiction go ahead yeah go in the original
one Charlton Heston they show the time
clock on their spaceship it goes
thousands of years thousands of years
yeah so from nineteen you know ninety or
whenever he supposedly leaves
so where do they get that date wrong
yeah
so this is what 15-20 years after
society collapsed yeah
my wife had a problem with this too but
so they're like I love the fact that
like our names Nova I love the callback
yeah to the original but I'm like so
this girl lives to be 3,500 years old or
where is that time that's a problem I
was the engineer ease of Novas every
girl born to her his name Nova yeah
better than they already know how to
talk anymore so yeah yeah so everyone
just they just hand down the yeah well
they did that twice they did it with her
and they did with Cornelius right so we
both her and Cornelius are three
thousand years old right or they've
named their next twenty children right
thousand children you know what I mean
like I with that I was thinking well
they're gonna mess with the taught their
everything is going to be a little bit
more radiant and read kind of timeline
yeah they're right they're just gonna
say oh there's the spaceship clock got
broken yeah I like that too considering
what else happens in that movie sure why
not yeah right I would buy the space
time clock got broken space clock went
nuts
hmm we're not three thousand years in
the future we're just like a hot 50 also
has to do is spin around wildly once I
mean you're like oh it's broken its
broken crazy clock right look my
coffeemaker was not working when I got
back from comic-con and that's you know
technology is on that just teeter-totter
edge there you never know when
something's going to just flip on you so
you're going to find a crumbled Statue
of Liberty on a beach is what you're
telling I'm gonna find a water coffee on
the beach
No you might ask you find my god strong
brew is dead Joe DiMaggio
no get it what were some of the other
Easter eggs at you noticed in the film
because I don't think I'm sure Graham
and I didn't see all of them well I mean
uh most the ones they did there were too
many veiled ones I mean the ones that
right off the bat yeah I mean like doing
the Nova thing I thought was wonderful
because I am look I'm your audience
I'm the guy you all you have to do is
provide me with all that little nerd fan
stuff and I'll go crazy I'm with you and
that's what bothered me about that movie
it's because I felt like it was
addressing me as a fan and someone who
you know respects this franchise but
then there were so many things that were
just sloppy bad screenwriting that we're
just like and it made the movie drag
like the whole prison section of that
film where the greatest day it's the
Great Escape and but it's a terrible
Great Escape and having little if I want
to see that movie yeah movie the fourth
in this series should be that the age
start turning well for whatever they
whatever color he went baseball yeah yes
but yeah I mean the breakout thing and
having the little Jar Jar Binks guy
running around as Steve Zahn mother
yeah that's jeeps on em did the zoo
primate who who got smarter yeah so got
smarter he's not one of them but he
taught himself to be smarter I liked him
in the very first scene I liked him and
I found it amusing where I was like okay
this is just to kind of introduce him
but he's going to play a more important
role instead of idiot loud-talking
a villain you need to be quiet
yeah again he was girl concept that guy
he's gonna he would go
no concept of stealth once again and and
you know him putting his little head up
in the holes that were under the prison
camp and like I mean for the virus
explains a lot if it's making humans
dumber right because these humans were
the dumbest humans at the way that they
protected that camp there was over like
one guard and he gets [ __ ] thrown on
them and then that tricks him into
unlocking the gate to confront the Apes
and then they'll go through that yeah
really really really guys they are
laughing in our faces with this kind of
thing I mean I just threw out that movie
having the little girl who decides to
walk into the prison camp and help
Caesar yeah no one noticed Anela notices
all yetis walk but that's the one-way
wall where isn't HAMP the wall wasn't
done yet
so then we need more guards right yeah
we need some guards how about some guard
just one who gets poo thrown on him
that's it yeah I mean and then the every
time the head comes up through the
little hole underground how about
there's a limp part where they go where
the little girl gets in she helps Caesar
gets him some food and water and then
leaves her little doll she has that
little doll shoe and it leaves it in the
cage and then woody harrelson notices it
and says do a sweep of the area
apparently that never happened because
the sweep of the area would have found
the eighth's yeah and also might have
found some holes in the ground and then
like oh hey maybe we should check out
under the ground because they've got to
know that all exist right II meant sweep
just a very small area or literally
sweep like just and crumbs and you know
to be nice humans isn't any dumber my
other thing us pants my other favourite
dumb human seed is whistle dead like so
but the other group of humans is now
coming to attack and the Apes for some
reason are now in the line of fire all
jumping around right and they they shoot
the Apes like as far as I know I don't
see any Apes with helicopters maybe we
should save some
tamo and pointed upward but I I mean
that kind of thing drives me crazy
and I felt it was a really a wasted
opportunity because everything else is
there
you've got the technology right amazing
performances I didn't I and even look I
wasn't crazy about woody harrelson with
the stupid sunglasses but okay I could
have I could have gone along with that
if everything else would have been there
and it wasn't well let's go into them
the ending because obviously this is
setting up now they've already said in
April and October of last year they said
they're already like in production or
pre-production for a fourth one even
though this right this is supposed to be
a trilogy those would be a trilogy why I
mean they're I mean III see whether
they're like whoa why are we tied into
three yeah these are making money let's
do another one
well I was talking to Grandpa this what
do you think about this Matt what if the
next movies weren't prequels they went
past the original 70s movies and we see
what happens after that would you like
to see those Japanese movie because at
some point you need to abandon some of
those people's you want to blow up the
planet yeah there's that one that killed
everybody let's just say that's one of
my favorites yeah maybe you don't like
the Navy eh it's okay but but no my
point is you're done you killed it's
over like you break the planet and now
we're going to go shopping in San
Francisco like yeah yeah yeah you
definitely have to that is my that is
one of my favorite dumb plot points of
all the time yeah you guys a read kind
of fair amount of that my favorite if
your listeners have never seen beneath
the plight of the Apes you have to see
it also and then immediately see escape
because the idea we have a shopping one
escape that's escape escape and with
escape the fact that like earlier in the
first play of the Apes movie Taylor
makes a paper airplane and they're like
Oh
cut to beneath they've now managed to
get this the original spaceship out of
the Forbidden Zone lake fix it and leave
the Earth's atmosphere like these are
some smart eggs a day like that's that's
pretty good and then go back in time and
once is there a TV show you oh yeah I
watch a TV show like so you have
you have all of this material that maybe
some of its cannon maybe some of it
isn't right you know you pick what you
want to it I'm saying just are there
stories to be told after the original
planet of the eggs are there are there
movies after that and and then the
ending of this of war where does war go
like where does war go and where like
where should it go in terms of the the
whole if you're going to continue doing
rewear dude you just redcon the whole
thing and then the next one is like we
have a recap we have a new tailor and a
new no Avadh we just like what do you do
well because the ending of this was
clearly like alright Moses has reached
the Promised Land
humans are awful though he was they're
going to kill themselves and they're all
getting the dumb virus and we're already
red counting out the Tim Burton version
so that's that's our thank you very
thank you I want to hug you can even
mention yeah like what's that ever I was
a favorite reenact fiction it's been
fiction fever dreams yeah yeah made for
people who not fans know maybe I don't
know who that's made for but yeah with
that but I really feel like are are
there more stories after the original
like are that we could do now with the
technology that we have well again
beneath is actually one of my favorite
eggs films because I when I saw that as
a kid I was well I saw this on TV
because you know I actually I'm old
enough to tell you that I saw plant Apes
the original in the theater as a kid and
this is rated G and there's a it was
rated G and there's a lot of [ __ ] that
will [ __ ] up a kid in that movie yet oh
my god don't humans and yeah yeah Taylor
getting shot the neck and all kinds of
horrible things well the other thing too
you have to understand about Planet of
the Apes so that came out in 1968
there's no there's a lot of Charles and
Harrison's character in the original one
I mean Rod Serling was one of the screen
yes right this is this is this is
brilliant science fiction so when they
land on the planet Charlton Heston keeps
writing that
other astronauts oh your idols in awliya
you are you know because I that guy they
were painting him as a sort of some sort
of whatever hero successful guy and
Charlton Heston's just gone everything
you thought was important it's in the
[ __ ] now pal like it was like wow he
was so dark and he was so this is what
you're fixating on my service record
yeah exactly like a bug too you know
yeah that's all great Taylor I'm looking
for water yeah right now I don't care
that you're talking about there was
lovemaking there's no love Dana Dana
Gould had this thing about like Stuart
you know though the girl the blond that
dies right and that there she's talking
about her is like if she was going to be
the ease right we were gonna be the
Adams like no I think she was probably
thought that she was going to be the
science officer I don't think I don't
think they even realize I'm going to be
getting them triple teamed by all these
oh my god take a number but but so
getting to your clients officer are you
[ __ ] mad Wow didn't read the fine
print
oh what you're saying about the sequel
spell is one of the things I loved about
beneath is that beneath went bonkers
look like you with planet you have a
pretty straightforward story with the
surprise ending right with beneath now
you've got mutants you've got a
dictatorial gorilla you've got all these
you've got a doomsday machine you don't
say that they and not only are they
mutants that have the ability to enter
your mind and make you fight or kill
each other against your will but you
have a group of people who are scarred
they were masked to cover that and they
worship an atomic bomb and by the end of
the film the earth ends and I remember
being a kid watching this on TV and
Taylor sets off the Alpha Omega bomb and
you've got like played by Charlton it's
actually Brent he's like no no Taylor's
the one who puts up that sets off the
bomb now yeah that's right
meet at the very front and they shot up
by Ursus that's right and they have that
weird scale area that weird it's 1970 so
they can't hug they have that weird
where they shake each other and that
weird man they want to hug each other
but they're a man the half shape man hug
they didn't close like I want to hug him
but Oh that'll make me I now have to
watch that God for that yeah I saw
because actually they replay when I
first moved to LA we talked about this
in the other episode I saw they played
these back-to-back at the new Beverly
when I first moved here in the 90s and I
was like oh they were so fantastic so
anyway you're right Taylor did come in
at the end and he blows up blows up the
entire earth and then he got all freeze
coming in at the end with the voice-over
you know and you know the third planet
from the Sun is now a burned-out cinder
but it was the way he said it though he
said he goes frying it small
insignificant
a said it's a smart and he also said a
small insignificant planet so it's just
I remember watching that as a kid like
wow so first of all we're just some
little speck of dust in the universe
right like all of a sudden now you're
getting existential yeah and you're like
oh why do is my rice in the world and
why don't I stick to my homework now
yeah and if we're gonna end because
obviously this was in the middle of the
Cold War yeah about us blowing each
other up that's done we don't worry
about that now everything's great on
planet earth but crew but that was I
remember that was a no one has missiles
but us that was a we're not we're very
responsible have other responsible
country Islands planet everything one
thing we don't make is mistakes yes we
can we learn from yeah we have a lot of
regime change books but I remember as a
kid that glare I was like terrified of
the like oh we're going to we're going
to end awesome the Soviets are going to
blow each other up oh yeah and this was
like and it seemed like such a big deal
and this went yeah if you dumb humans
can't get along
who cares you're going to blow your
little small planet is over and no one
will notice how well the aliens
yeah yeah and I remember watching that
and and like wait a minute that's the
end like it's the end yeah and on top
for everything for everyone the entire
earth is dead and also it's a more
sobering but but still as as poignant as
dr. Strangelove's ending both of them
end with right it's over this one
beneath is like real serious and and dr.
strange I was like haha yeah escape kind
of pretty much goes with the premise of
well the second ones it kind of didn't
happen no it does no the second they go
back in time they ran in time before it
half they go back in time before it
happened
and what you get with escape I guess too
was you know beneath was so heavy that
they figured all right you know we got
to do we got to lighten it up we got to
do a love American style eight film we
got it yeah I saw nothing
rather than that girl that yeah yeah
daisies roses yep somebody's going to
lose a kite yeah yeah you can turn very
well down with a smile serious ease
yourself as a mannequin yeah yeah oh god
I want to make that now but but I think
that they felt like they had to lighten
it up and then after that then you get
into conquest where it's now back to
dead serious right and it's civil rights
and I remember watching that in the
theater and now this is there's two
versions of that the ones they released
in the theater where they had to recut
the film at the end of the movie it's
basically rise is conquest and Caesar
originally played by writing McDowell at
the end of that movie he's taken over
this ape complex and they're all about
to slaughter the humans and he says but
we will put down our weapons because
they did a test screening and people got
too into the Apes slaughtering all the
humans it was so dark and right now when
you get the the box sets they include
that original director Scott where they
slaughter everybody oh wow and it's
great and that's the defendant of one to
see I think now but but I remember
seeing that in the theater but where did
where did the TV show fit in the time
line I think it was it was not it was it
was an alternative right history because
the Apes in that one I mean I guess you
could say if you wanted to play with it
a little bit the human beings were not
that smart but they weren't really it
wasn't that they weren't smart they just
weren't educated right and they could
still speak and so I guess you could
argue that maybe gradually over another
100 years what's another hundred years
and one of the Apes right right never
taken that they forget how to speak and
but but that that was another one the TV
show because I bought growing up Apes
free cattle the Mego figures was into it
and then the show comes out like oh my
god a plant eh TV show the first ones
okay you know they land and then all
right there's the IRS's kind of
character and then by the end of it it
was like I don't know like they had a
bunch of scripts that were from Quincy
yeah like couple of Rockford Files here
just change Apes
it'll be a Chicago ape City okay
anything well it is a policewoman strip
river shot I mean I was one there was
actually one episode where it's like you
know there's cheating they're having a
horse race and there's there's you know
they're cheating on the horse race and
so humans got together like what the
[ __ ] it's the planets and the stories
about a crooked horse race we take
gambling serious yeah yeah that speech
must not cheap
I remember the show not lasting very
long no that was one reason it was a
yeah I remember I did the same thing I
was a kid I was so into Planet of the
Apes and then I watched a couple and I
remember the TV shows like this will be
awesome about two episodes then I was
like imagine if occasionally my name
children with your show like really I
mean this is you've lost you yeah this
is this is you know that the bar was
pretty low we would have liked okay but
let's get back yeah
and it's like the thing with superhero
stuff now is like superhero shows back
then it's like you know if you made it
just like the comic we don't love it and
it ran forever forever forever so let's
go back though to the ending of this
movie war for the Planet of the Apes
right the humans kill each other the
Apes make it out of they survive the
humans don't kill each other well it's a
it's a act of God right an abbess an
avalanche which another giant problem
like that was just like it was a very
selective red land and this because it
was a lot of it was interesting because
it was a lot of troops and like oh
there's a lot of troops left and they're
all in winter gear
I wonder what's going to happen oh we're
going to get rid of him within that plan
I wanted to see you like one of them
like Wiley coyote like pull out the
little umbrella yeah exactly
get him with a sign that says yikes so
what did you think of that ending though
so like and and where does that it had
to get rid of a lot of it so your head
to get rid of them but yes so you're
saying act of God and then weird where
do the Apes who have now survived a
human avalanche okay where did I go
where do we go well so you're left with
the impression that because we Harrelson
says well they're going to send
everybody against me so you're left with
the impression that that's if very at
least a the majority of human beings now
are wiped out and majority of the
weaponry and the weapons of the killing
so they said that was the whole
remaining army because who hasn't died
from the simian flu this is they're
sending all the big guns down so there's
not much that the rest of the
helicopters right yes yeah yeah
helicopters tanks the majority of them
just got wiped out yeah at a ski resort
worst vacation ever
but the is this a prequel the hot dog
was build wire and hot dog - oh my god I
hope this medium ski school housekeeper
thank you
I should know this this is but so at the
end they escape the humans they find
their shangri-la they find their Israel
and they you know everyone's happy and
then we I saw this coming but again this
is a spoiler thing right yeah say
whatever that Caesar is mortally injured
right and you why the soldier that he
saved in the beginning yeah which that
was another thing that was just a red
herring that was unsatisfying the idea
that you build this guy up to maybe be
this something the one here the one
human that sympathetic human and that
just kind of goes nowhere
but okay fine he's mortally wounded and
he's dying I didn't mind the idea that
Caesar dies right because I felt like
okay let's tell and we can tell a new
story now yeah if they make more movies
right but and but I did way again the
way that movie that scene was done I
felt came off a little silly except for
his dying scene that all of a sudden
everyone's jumping around and no one
really notices that hey how you doing
Caesar right well I seem to see a trail
of blood coming after you and are you
okay and that that's the other thing too
is like how about medicine like how
about isn't there something that they
can do to try to help him because it
didn't seem like even that was done he
was just hiding his room why why not
have they do whatever they can to save
him well again I don't want to have to
have a heroic death I get it I
understand I was actually alright with
that because the idea that they found
their place okay what we know is that no
place is ever safe so this is just a
momentary respite from whatever new set
of horrors and what I'm hoping if they
are going to still play around with all
the stuff from the last movies and throw
in the Easter eggs I would love to see
some mutants right a leftover you know
remnants of humanity that's why I
thought there might have been a nuclear
thing in this to sort of set that up
Dage yeah well then the earth one was
all
the first one was like this is this is a
post new killer Holocaust yeah there's a
reason why it's the Forbidden Zone
tonight nuclear radiation all right yeah
but I hope that they at least now that
they've told their Caesar story I would
like to see them go a little crazy have
a little fun with waking mythology with
mythology it's the future
Cornelius rising up yeah and and that
are we going to then see the battle
between the the chimps and the gorillas
in terms of life
you know that was like like battle yeah
like battle for dominance but that was
also a nerd that was very much
introduced in the first and the first
one yes Cornelius was a scientist and
you know and all that stuff but but the
gorillas are war war light and I love
how they switch it because actually a
nature chimpanzees are way more violent
and get away yeah I mean they're if you
ever study anything about the wars that
chimpanzees have amongst each other
they're ruthless really oh yeah
and now they'll like don't be hair
another chimpanzee to pieces right as a
kind of a almost like a symbol to the
other group you know the other tribe of
chimpanzees but but yeah I always
thought that was kind of funny and now
what I liked about this movie is that
they kind of switched it back right that
because most of the Apes in those movies
are chimpanzees right and and the
gorillas were the ones that sort of were
docile and got well that that turned the
general turn yeah that's a turn that did
that just acquiesced to the power of the
the war of the humans yeah trying to say
my favorite scene in that movie and I
know a lot of people have also pointed
this out but what I really that's scene
where Maurice finds a little girl is
like I could watch that again and again
right how subtle that thing is and how
moving it is and how it's no dialogue
no and I yeah I wanna I definitely
recommend
that you see this movie I mean just a
few just to acknowledge the technology
in this film where motion-captured Apes
look so realistic that they can make you
feel those kinds of emotion even with
acting with or without human
counterparts it's it's a I mean it's n't
without a doubt I think I think if you
like the first two you should see this
and I think there are definitely some
flaws and problems in it but there are
some amazing moments Aaron what did you
clearly agree on I loved it I wanted to
see if our resident expert noticed this
when Maurice speaks and he says know his
name to her it's Charlton Heston from 68
it's his voice I did not get that
no audio guy I picked it outta me no I
didn't Wow not review us anywhere but is
that right wow you are good yeah
I I really wish my crown to you yeah
yeah
she put that on IMDB oh yeah you should
put I'll get no credits yeah yeah and
and in terms of where the the franchise
goes from here I also read in the trivia
that this is the first in the franchise
of this new franchise that doesn't
mention the original novel as source
material so they can kind of go anywhere
I think my my guess any mutants at some
point I my guess is they're gonna
they're going to since these movies do
well and they are pretty entertaining
right and they do have decent social
commentary my guess is they're going to
just read Khan the whole timeline just
start a holding right right let's go
start running should and they should and
they'll give me a see Easter eggs a
spaceships gonna crash and the Taylor's
gonna walk out yeah right you know and
it's all of that is fine but you don't
have to again you don't have to link it
directly to the original series you
shouldn't I be real serious kind of went
all over the place as we discussed yeah
yeah yeah it's it's it miss yeah it's it
miss I was going back to it now there's
a lot of even like escape which I always
felt was a weaker one when I watch it
now
I kind of liked it more because it's a
thing of its time okay so I get that but
we have those films right we don't need
it's like but the Star Trek films you
don't need to do Khan again let's see
something else right
yeah you don't need to do the same thing
worse yeah true yeah that's that should
be very wise word yes mr. Matthew um all
right well I think that L just can't be
yet yeah final thoughts Matt Whitehall
Red Dawn
now head Swayze's Masterson I believe
Dana right now and hopefully I'm correct
with all this information but I think
he's working on doing like a graphic
novel of the original really rod serling
script Oh
because well we now he has not tipton in
here who wrote the crossover with Star
Trek on the Planet of the Apes and they
had on which I really enjoyed I enjoyed
it as well so Chris kagra for me as a
gift
yeah yeah I was like oh you got it Kirk
meets Taylor how can happily not and it
works I know of course and so great and
it had all of Dana's essays at the end
yes which was really cool yeah and what
we haven't discussed is by briefly we
should very briefly the animated series
oh I forgot it was an animated Saturday
morning TV series that was really based
on the book because it the Apes have
tanks and jeeps and spaceships and all
kinds of stuff and so it's they have a
regular technological society and yeah I
mean it's it's horrible animation yes I
actually have an animation cell which I
think there were three was how much yeah
yeah I was not that much movement yeah
but but it as an oddity it's worth
checking out just because the fact that
this you know they cobbled this thing
together and I think they get I can't
remember the actors name but they get
and as a voice actor I think the guy
from beneath okay the black dude and
beneath right yeah I can't I'm tryna
remember his name right
alright alright well that was that was
good glad to have Matt join us Matt
where can people find you on the
Internet oh uh Facebook there's my
website Matt Weinhold calm you can get
my CD dead funny
a comedy film that yes and a comedy film
nerds and check us out on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram monster party
great show it's a blab you guys do a lot
of much because it's just it's it's
solid nerdery yeah it is very solid
spirit intense passionate nerdism yep we
have a lot of great guests as right here
very passionate co-hosts yes the one
thing I can say about this podcast is it
you're not going to get cool uh you know
savvy nerds these are my friends these
are real nerds so and they act like
nerds and I you know I don't see a lot
of sunlight you know oh no no no we
almost come to blows over things that
aren't really that important yeah yeah
it did bring me back to the likes heated
arguments I had when I was like 19 about
crap that's not that important no no but
it delights me to say like oh my god
you're one of our hosts Larry can get
apoplectic over things like you know
running zombies yeah to the point where
now I just bait him now it's just like
well if it were running zombie be much
better yeah yeah
and then you add liquor to that and yeah
it's a fight what it was jogging you
know you're gonna forget jogging that's
always a lot like the walking dead just
walk a little faster with running
zombies as you stir your ass you're dead
well that's it guys that's the war for
the Planet of the Apes spoiler up we
love doing these as we said because the
patreon hit the thousand dollar level
will do into your month if you can get
us to the next level of patreon we can
do more cool stuff more video shows
right now we're just cutting up the
video from these episodes but we want to
do more video interviews and all kinds
of different stuff so thank you guys so
much for supporting the show of course
patreon.com slash comedy thunder and
thank you so much Matt wine hole I love
you guys I mean that go ahead to have
here we love you now just got once again
got uncomfortable it really did it's
weird
you're the one who had the problem with
the tailor Brunton ijen hailer brenton
to you this you were being legitimate
and then I went okay all right mr Dunne
you went ahead and did it you felt
something damn you Brent and one
insignificant little podcast blows up a
day now a tiny piece of my heart thank
your bran guard and everybody at the all
things comedy world headquarters my name
is Graham Elwood and I'm Cris Mancini
and as always remember Han shot first
Rhett comment you maniacs you finally
done it